back in Sydney where did that bird go
the the cowbird yeah oh we're really in
Australia now today we're eating steak
starting Sydney Adam expected Chris
steak
what's going on here whoa I don't think
people could appreciate how great this
tree is you certainly can because you're
stupid
all right let's go eat some steak get
your hair saliva rolling today I'm worth
it Australia edition we're gonna have
three steaks at three drastically
different price points to find out which
steak in Australia is the most worth it
at its price remember when we had steak
before we'll be surpassed today I'm
pretty sure this is gonna be like that
he'll stick tacular we're actually
arriving right now look at that hey it's
the ocean all great restaurants are at
the ocean thank you you want to be the
hub all righty take my mic here take it
let's go I'll be camera guy for a day hi
I'm Stephen
my name's Sebastian the toad and we're
at the Cavalli Hotel hosted the beach
today we're going to be having a sixteen
dollar steak that we have on our steak
nights on Wednesday it's a piece of rum
rum rum it's part of the meat it's a
little bit tougher near the back of the
shoulder their arms got a lot more
flavor because it's a muscle that works
at before the rump will come in
portioned salt pepper I don't do
anything else no spices or anything on
it it's a bit of rush of bone marrow
that we've been melted down just a bit
extra flavors with rosemary and thyme in
it straight onto the top of the boiler
get a nice char on it both sides then
straight into the boiler in the middle
we're about 700 degrees child out for
about two or three minutes both sides
and then let it rest steaks today's
maybe you're coming with me and beans
and mash we're both pretty new to
Australian beers is there one you'd
recommend for us to have with this steak
you know what is a bull poke one hole
poke used to be an old Prime Minister of
Australia
he's got reputation for skull and the
fastest beer really yes Cheers
to the Prime Minister of Australia
that's nice
that's refreshing you know what that is
right there no rum that's wrong Oh
excellent do you wanna do Oh mine's
better dog burger is better by default
that is mine Cheers
that's nice mmm that's amazing that
that's just salt pepper and bone marrow
it's also a steak okay
it adds a lot to the flavor it's a
little bit Meteor chewy and it does have
that beefy or taste that you get with
the rump with the roast cuts $16 that's
really nice that could be read that your
friends like what else do you need you
want some that's really good right Adam
just said it's really good just not him
you just not it he just went it's subtle
the way that he moves I what are some
good Australian Britain games and we're
out of pub I feel like this is
appropriate time to puff it up yeah
where do we start so there's one we've
obviously you get a corn so you choose
heads or tails whatever it lands you get
to scale the B if you lose $2 coin I
call it loser downs it in the down under
heads what is gonna be let the record
show that the coin landed tails was head
look that's not going down Adam he saved
me here
host Oh
maybe he should be the next prime
minister there's a tasty steak with a
well done
medium-rare steak Oh oh yeah look at
that
why the crevasse I saved you why you
thankful steak back 70 percent of cattle
raised in Australia are grass-fed who
spend their entire life grazing freely
that's a good ratio right I graze freely
I'm happy
are you a pre grazer I'm the graze
Gatsby Grey's Anatomy crazy in love
Beyonce oh nice hello my name is Kevin
Donovan
I'm the owner of gentleman's restaurant
along with my wife Gail wanted to create
a relaxed comfortable environment on st.
kilda beach it's really you know if Gail
changes the interior accents of the
restaurant every six months she likes as
the colors the restaurant changes the
displays and people come to the
restaurant every six months a what's new
what did they change everything's very
cozy I feel I feel very sated and like
comfortable here and that's exactly what
we're trying to create Emma our chef has
been with us for 15 years she's gonna
show you how we cook our Tasmanian
wilderness beef t-bone my name is Emma
della Sandra and I'm the head chef at
Donovan's restaurant here in san kyoudai
and today we're gonna cook the grass-fed
British cattle breed t-bone on the
charcoal oven so in order we'll come in
we pull it out brush it with a little
bit of oil season it with salt and
pepper the Jasper oven that I cook it in
sits at about 350 degrees Celsius pop it
in the oven and then we constantly turn
it till it gets a really nice
caramelization crust on it and then I'll
bring it out and I'll rest it so for as
long as I've cooked it arrested for the
same amount of time when I go to cut it
Liv's not going to use that all over the
plate so you just get this really nice
tender juicy piece of meat with that you
get a scotch ipsec rosemary salt and
fried garlic little salad of bay because
leaves just with a lemon vinaigrette it
makes a complete meal which is great
when you're paying that sort of price
for a piece of meat
in beef let's eat potato Cheers
potato Cheers mmm holy crap that is the
most potato we've potato I've ever eaten
great I do all right let's go oh I went
right through
cheers Cheers
that awkward moment when you hold your
food cheers for a lot hmm this is a
great steak even that medium-rare is
inside that's that bake it's familiar in
that it's a steak but it really tastes
like a wild animal it's a whole other
experience on the other side of the
t-bone it's so different the meat that's
right next to the bone that's what I
mean by bone means like brisket the bone
me the bone me he knows what side look
at that bone meat right there I'm gonna
let Adam have some of mine because it's
not as not on as yours who's a better
dinner guest
how do you know when somebody enjoys
your food when they eat like this yes
sir Donovan's is right there
that would come out for the beach for
just a moment at steak made me feel
things I've never felt before all the
meat off like a hyena yes like a
Tasmanian Devil it was that was
Tasmanian beef all right here we go
so next up is a steak fact one two three
as of June 2017 there was a bill
attempting to prohibit Australian cattle
that are exported from being labeled as
Australian beef after there didn't
process in the countries that import
them to be sold Oh cuz they're not
processing it good enough it doesn't
meet their standards so we're underway
to last steak place it's back in Sydney
but before we go I have a treat for you
I want to go to the farm where the wag
you was raised let's go meet some cows
my name is David Blackwell I'm the
founder of black male newbie this farm
is a breeding farm the calves are born
here and conceived here what is waiting
here reg you be physician is breed of
cattle a lot of people think it's a
process the Japanese have got this
unbelievable breed of cattle the
producers unbelievable meat how the hell
did they do it you're talking about very
very accurate information average daily
weight gain the marbling school every
animal has a different host stream that
was how they been able to make sure that
there was no cheating keep accurate
records I can do this for probably at
least ten generations on all these
cattle that are behind us
we've got an unbelievable database with
over 10,000 animals now recorded so we
can look at that and see which are our
best breeding cows and which are the
best moves that they breed to what makes
a cow delicious to be honest a lot a lot
and I know that's much sound really
really cool but the main thing that can
affect the quality of meat is whether
the cow has been under stressed so we
actually monitor everything from prior
to conception right through to the
weaning of the car from in every other
stage right through as well you know I
like the fact that we can put flavor
into beef and make it something really
different and special dual ovary and it
is I do love I gotta say truly this has
been the coolest experience yeah it's
been great fun having you guys here too
my name is Cory Costello I'm the head
chef here at Rockwell Bar and Grill in
Sydney and today you guys gonna be
having two of the David Blackmore Wagyu
steak we get a lot of whole animals it
when we break them down into all the
different various cuts but then we have
them all aging up in a room what is the
advantage of dry aging me the natural
moisture that's in the meat when you
dredge it intensifies that moisture like
reducing a stock down and making it more
flavor soon the first thing you guys
would be eating will be why do I have
Chuck really really big in flavor and we
actually we never used to serve it as a
steak we used to cut it up and braise it
all the chefs would come along and cut
off the first cuts of them and start
eating them in amateurs like that's it
if this is good enough for all of us to
eat it's good enough to the guests so a
new steak was born our butcher well aged
them anywhere between 21 up to about 75
days and we very very lightly sprinkle
them with salt a little bit of oil and
then we cook it over a wood fire grill
crusted up on the each side and then
just before the guests are ready to eat
it we give it a little here up again and
then I slice it on a board certain
stakes have grains that run through them
and we try and cut them out so that the
guest gets the best experience that's
just for our time in Australia salt cow
sure did
yeah it still gets me know if first sip
of wine always still just the current
table setting onion rings and steak is
child Andrews perfect table setting to
hard
I'm like the God Wow just straight-up
fun yeah that's crazy
that's so good oh no wait long enough so
this is the eye of the chuck this is the
cut that chefs prefer to eat when they
come to Rockwall are you ready to put
this in your mouth who are you talking
to you oh okay yeah I am
Cheers
[Music]
hmm I'm just gonna go right back mmm
all the best things in life are done
with your eyes closed sleeping making
out I can't disagree with that so really
good oh it tastes like a beef stock
turned into bubblegum it's reverse
bubblegum it's reverse bubblegum better
the more you chew into it the next one
you have is a grass-fed sirloin from
sort of the middle of the back of the
animal very high marbles beautiful
eating we've got it for 150 dollars on
the menu at the moment so bargain
bargain at 135 150 low comes at lemon
yeah immediately visually oh this one
looks easy compared to the other says
old me with your zest not literally me
look at that marble and the grain
structure is crazy it's like a comb of
me Pierce to all of Australia
that has a very intense flavor about in
blind don't worry we won't make out it's
so easy to eat I can't slow down and
it's already cut for you that could
demolish one of these in about five
minutes if I was by myself not trying to
be conscious of other people watching me
there's only salt and lemon on this guy
all of the flavor is baked into the cow
I just want to say here enjoy this for
the rest of my life
well you can't cuz I'm about to eat it
all ready to go home I'm coming oh yeah
and with that back in the States
back in the worth it mobile driving back
on the right side of the road and it's
the correct side or the right side boat
alright so the trip is over but we must
now decide which stake was the most
worth it to you at its price in
Australia the Clovelly Hotel at an
amazing value state that would be the
perfect post Beach steak you eat post
beach steaks pretty Beach free Beach
steaks the steak that was most worth it
to me at its price was certainly
Donovan's I name anything that mean that
place is what I would want a restaurant
to look like if I operated it here's
what I'll say about this steak video
every location was amazing but there
must be a winner a winner goes to rock
pool
whoa it's not that one $50 strong it's
the I jump it's the eye of the chair
Huck it's the thrill of this day right
Adam five four five what you guys chose
the same thing we're halfway through the
season and you guys are the same person
it only gets better from here so you
kids could get worse that's what you
call a teaser what do you think
Australians call up here because we call
that Down Under
are we up over all right
Australia over oh yes